isn't the only way to bundle up
your JavaScript. We also have
things like Browserify, Rollup,
and SystemJS. These things all
bundle up your ES6 modulesm and
it doesn't really matter which
one you use. That comes down to
a personal preference.
Webpack seems to be the most
popular, and I'd recommend that
you go with that. However, it's
not like you're writing Webpack
modules or Browserify modules.
You're writing a standard ES6
module, so if you were to switch
out your bundler at any time,
you should be able to do that
with no problem. There's
another one called SystemJS that
works with something called jspm.
Jspm is JavaScript Package
Manager, and it sits on top of
npm. It's not like an
alternative to npm, it just sits
on top of it. Why am I
looking at SystemJS right here?
One really cool feature of
SystemJS is that you can
possibly run it in the browser,
which means that you don't need
any of the overhead of npm
installing Webpack, getting
these bundlers up and running,
getting your Babel and your
transpiler on the right presets,
and all of that hard work that
we just did in the last couple
ones. Sometimes that can be
a bit of a barrier to entry when
you just want to try something
out, or you got a couple of
hours on a Friday night and you
want to hack on something. You
don't want the tooling to get in
your way. SystemJS, really
how you do it is you load in a
script tag to jspm.io/system@19
and that's going to load the
latest 19.x version. Then we
also need to run this HTML
through some sort of server. If
you have a server, if you have a
little Python server, if you
have maybe a PHP server, feel
free to run it through this. It
just needs to not run on a file.
It needs to run on a local host
or something like that. I'm
going to set up a quick little
browser sync server. If you're
interested in how to do that,
I'm going to do that now.
Otherwise, just scrub forward
for a couple minutes and you can
skip this part. What am I
going to do? I'm going to open
up my terminal here. I'm in the
ES6 tooling folder, and I'm
going to go into my SystemJS
folder. I need to do an npm.
Again, this isn't npm because we
need it for the module bundling.
This is just because I need it
for doing the browser sync. I'm
going to set that thing up. Good.
Then I'm going to install
browser-sync--savedev. I'm going
to go to my package.json and
delete that test one that we had
there, and create a server
script, and paste in browser-
sync, start sever. These need to
be single quotes. Start
directory, server, files, and
then we're going to watch all of
our JavaScript HTML and our CSS
files. If we've done that
correctly, we should be able to
head back to where we installed
browser sync, which you see in
our package.json. We have a dev
dependency of browser sync, and
we should be able to npm run
server. That will then open
up a little server for you. You
should see index.html, which I
have there for you, and then any
other files that you have in
there. That's just a quick and
dirty little server if you ever
need one. I prefer browser sync,
because any time I make a save
it's going to refresh it for me
without any extra work. Cool.
Let's head back to our index.
html here. We've loaded up jspm,
and then we're going to give
ourselves a script tag. The
script tag is just going to do
two things. First, it's going to
configure SystemJS, and then
it's going to enter our entry
point, which we'll create in a
second. We'll say system.
config, and then system.config
takes an object, which is just a
transpiler We are using Babel,so
you just pass it Babel. Then we
also need a place, where should
it grab the entire application
from? Last time we had app.js.
Let's go into our SystemJS
folder, and we'll call this main.
js, just as a different name.
In here let's just say console.
log Hey it works. Then back to
our index.html, we'll say system.
import, and then you import the
actual application that you want.
After we're done all of that, we
can go back to our main.js and
just write our modules as we had
in the other tutorials. I think
if I go index.html and open up
my DevTools here we should see,
Hey, it works. The really
cool part about using SystemJS
is that I don't need to npm
install, or do any of the stuff
that we've previously done.
Let's say I wanted to get some
methods from lodash, so we'll
say import, and this time let's
get some and kebabCase. We'll
get that from lodash. That's how
you normally would do it.
However, we need to say npm
lodash. What that's going to do
is go to npm's registry and
import lodash for us. If I say
kebabCase, console.log kebabCase
Wes is so cool. Put a
couple emojis in there just for
some metal. Then we should be
able to refresh this page. It
takes a second now. See, it's
not immediately showing up, but
after a second or two Wes is so
cool is running. I didn't npm
install anything. I'm just able
to go ahead and import things.
Same thing if I had my own
module, go to SystemJS, new file,
let's call it checkout.js, and
we have a function in here
called addTax, takes in an
amount and a tax rate, and then
it's going to return to us the
amount plus the amount times tax
rate. If I want to make that
available, I would export it,
then we just go back to our main.
js, import, call it addTax from,
then you just give it a relative
path, checkout. We should be
able to console.log, addTax, a $
100 bill at 015 percent tax rate.
Give it a second and it gives us $
115. That is so much better
than having to set up all of
those tools that we did for 20
minutes in the last video, where
you just need to import this.
I think that is a great way to
show someone how modules work. I
think that's a great way, if you
just need to get something
working, or if you're trying to
explain something and you need
to set up a test case, and you
don't have to make anyone else
npm install all of your stuff.
You just use it all client side.
Obviously, it's not something
you do for production as it is
quite slow, but it's great for
just testing things out.